Мої вітання!
Сьогодні маю для вас декілька новин
Після запуску Всеукраїнської школи онлайн
я отримала від вас
безліч відгуків та запитань щодо організації
дистанційного навчання
для учнів початкової школи
Тому, насамперед, гарна новина
для наймолодших школярів та їхніх батьків
Незабаром для учнів з 1 по 4 клас
почнеться трансляція відеоуроків
чотирьох предметів:
Українська мова, математика, наука і мистецтво
Ну, і як же без корисних розваг?
Після закінчення уроків на учнів щоразу чекатиме
цікавий мультфільм про дивовижні факти
з історії нашої країни
А ще Всеукраїнська школа онлайн
стає безбар'єрною
Всі відеоуроки будуть супроводжуватись перекладом жестовою мовою
А для дітей з порушеннями зору
створюються версії із звукоописом
Адаптовані відеоуроки будуть доступні на
YouTube-каналі Міністерства освіти і науки
Користуючись нагодою, хочу подякувати
всім українським вчителям
Ви неймовірно швидко опановуєте
нові технології та формати
Вчитесь самі, аби продовжувати
навчати наших дітей
Спасибі вам!